so the topic is from health data to
location traces addressing spatial
temporal correlations and differential
privacy warning in a really wonderful
opportunity to listen to the great talks
in the past few days so what I want to
do today is to share some of our
research with you mainly focusing on two
projects so currently we're working on
two main directions related to data
privacy the first one is to build
clinical data registries for health
research with privacy and this is funded
by NIH and P quarry and the other one is
focusing on spatial temporal privacy for
location-based services so the setting
is we have one mobile user and whose
wants to use location-based services
such as looking for nearby restaurants
in this Berkeley area how to protect the
location of this user without disclosing
the price precise location to app
service providers or other third party
apps so these two seemingly different
applications one is focusing on the
aggregated population data health data
the other one is focusing on one single
individual user the mobility data they
seemingly very different however there's
some common lessons we learned common
insights we learned so what I want to
share with you is these three lessons
the first one is how do we model spatial
temporal correlations within the data so
that we can enhance the utility and
mobility data health data or a lot of
other data these days there are two key
dimensions one is space one is time
they're increasingly spatially
temporally correlated so how do we
actually modeled on to capture these
correlations we need this data so that
we can preserve this while we release
differential privacy this takes models
and so on and the flipside is this the
spatial temporal correlations can be a
blessing it can be also a curse if we
don't model them explicitly
if the adversary's actually have
knowledge of such correlations and a lot
of times they can learn is very easily
from publicly available trajectory data
for
they can use this to do inferences which
may actually grate the privacy guarantee
we intended to have and finally how do
we turn this curse into a blessing which
means we can explicitly model this
spatial temporal correlations maybe in
our privacy definitions or privacy
notions so maybe we could have a weaker
notion of privacy but with enhanced
privacy utility guarantee so in the
interest of time I was planning to do
all three of this but in interest time I
think I decided to do the first one and
the third one and we'll skip the second
lesson so let's start with the clinical
data registry project the main goal is
to take the original health records the
EHR data and try to develop privacy
mechanisms so that we can share
differential private or private
statistics or in ideal case we want to
share the synthetic records which mimics
the original data so that the
researchers can take the synthetic data
and do whatever analysis they want to do
and I don't think I need to motivate
this too much but the current practice
is still in the hospital or institutions
that only large amount of EHR data the
current practice is still to either go
for raw data that go through the IRB
process which has a lot of overhead and
does not allow large-scale uses of such
data for secondary use and the other
alternative approach is to use the
identified data which are exempt from
the HIPAA we have a law professor on the
first day talking about HIPAA and we all
know such approach that removes the
HIPAA safe-harbor identifiers are
actually subject to various
reunification or disclosure risks and it
has a lack of transparency and
accountability so it's not very robust
however is still the dominant approach
and in fact this is still how we got our
data for our research we got a version
of the identified data from our Hospital
to do our research
so what does the data look like the EHR
data this is the I to be to star schema
that's using most of the clinical data
warehouses around the nation and it
looks kind of messy but really the key
table here is the observation fact table
where each row in this table is
associated with the patient a visit and
a concept and some other information so
patient is going to be joint with a
patient dimension where it lists the
information about the patient
it can include birth date the sex the
race some other optional information and
then the visit means it could be a
either clinic visit or a hospital visit
or just some lab performance that can be
coded as a visit as well and then
there's concept that's the key
information so the concept can be either
a medication or diagnosis or procedure
or lab result and then all the related
information was that so each row
basically records the patient and then
one visit and then observations
associated with this visit which the
medication procedures lab lab tests and
so on so forth so as you can imagine
this data can be very complex high
dimensional sparse longitudinal and
essentially you can think of this data
as a sequence of timed visit for each
patient there's an event sequence event
for each time event there could be
multiple observations such as
medications diagnosis and procedures and
so on so forth and inherently you can
imagine there's a lot of correlations
among this data right in the strictest
in the structural or spatial dimension
there could be call currencies or
correlations among the procedures
medications diagnosis certain diagnosis
always co-occur with certain medications
there's also the temporal dependencies
certain diagnosis or combination of
diagnosis and medications could lead to
a future medication or diagnosis after
certain period of the time so our goal
is to really
try to learn such spatial temporal
correlations preserve it and then we can
release differentially private
statistics or models or synthetic data
that preserves such correlations so that
the medical researchers can still do the
studies that depends on a lot of times
depends on these correlations so here
are some of our efforts along this
direction we started with very simple
methods such as how can we preserve the
temporal patterns we took it as a
piecemeal approach kind of we started
with asking questions how can we
preserve the temporal patterns or how
can we preserve the spatial or
Corcoran's patterns and then can we
actually do this in the joint fashion so
I will show you some of our efforts and
some of them are successful some of them
are failures and I would of course
welcome any comments suggestions so the
first thing we tried is okay now we have
these timed sequences and the time
sequence is a very very sparse and if we
kind of synchronize all these time
sequences based on their time we're
gonna have ended up having a very very
sparse data set so the first thing we
try it is okay why don't we get rid of
the time just think about just keep the
ordering information right so we know
the order of certain diagnosis happening
before the next diagnosis if we have
these order information we can already
preserve some temporal patterns or learn
some temporal patterns certain diagnosis
always happens before or leads to
another diagnosis so here's a very
simple table which is extracted from the
data where each sequence is basically a
list of icd-9 codes the diagnosis codes
so this is just for illustration you can
imagine we could also have a hybrid
sequences here which consists of both
the diagnosis code or medication orders
with some other information now given
this what we want to preserve what we're
gonna find is frequent patterns like
this if this icd-9 code always happens
ahead of another icd-9 codes and if a
lot of patients or enough number of
patients based on a certain threshold
exhibit this patterns then this could be
a second
candor interesting tempura pattern that
we want to preserve we want to study
something order to do this this is a
common problem that we call frequent
pattern mining or sequential pattern
mining problem and in fact we did some
of this in our earlier work try to find
sequential pattern mining with
differential privacy and basically
looking at a data set with sequences and
we want to find the frequent patterns
that have enough of support based on the
number of records that have this pattern
right and there are a lot of algorithms
that are developed in a data mining
community for doing this kind of tasks
and of course our contribution here is
how do we do this with differential
privacy where's good utility many
algorithms the naive algorithm could be
okay as we count okay this is the
pattern and how many users have this
pattern and we can add Laplace noise to
this count and by now you've li doing
this the count can be not very accurate
and as the result the frequent patterns
may not be very accurate so our in our
approach we did some first pruning based
approach or sampling based approach to
kind of improve the sensitivity so we
get better utility out of it so based on
this work we decided okay let's apply
this to this data set that we have from
Emory and UC San Diego as part of our
study so this is what the data set looks
like from Emory we have about 300,000
patients and about 1 million 1.5 million
encounters or click visits so basically
each encounter is one event as I
mentioned earlier in the sequence time
events and this is the number of icd-9
codes 11,000 NiCd 9 codes at Emory and
at UCSD we have a much smaller data set
and as we extract the data into the
sequence format as we showed earlier we
have about two hundred ninety nine
thousand sequences for Emory because
some patients do not have icd-9 codes
associated with the data
so this ic9 data set only have about 300
sequences and we can actually observe
the maximum length of the icd-9 codes
for a patient is about 180
so this is probably a patient that have
a lot of codes a lot of diagnosis a lot
of visits but on average each patient
has about four icd-9 codes in its data
set so as we apply that frequent pattern
mining with differential privacy
algorithms on this data what we realize
what we got is that this is the f1 score
showing how accurate the frequent
patterns that we mind with differential
privacy compared to the non
differentially private version or the
basic baseline version I so the x-axis
is the epsilon and y-axis is the f1
score and different lines actually shows
the different data sets we have so very
soon we realized as we directly apply to
ours and very soon we'll realize these
lines that are very low they do not work
very well apparently the f1 scores about
0.4 it's very bad so we sort of realized
the reason is the number of icd-9 codes
is very very large which is about 10,000
so the domain is just too large for
their usual frequent pattern mining
approach to work so one fix or one
attempt we did is to apply the CCS
category which is the icd-9
hierarchy kind of a tautology so we
apply that and generalize some of the
icd-9 codes so that at the end we end up
having smaller number of icd-9 codes a
smaller domain and that ended up
improving the performance dramatically
so does that mean that the analysis
wasn't going to be any good even if you
didn't do privacy protection this you
mean the this is I've just find
interpret what you just said right those
data sets weren't very informative
whether you did privacy protection or
not because the
statistical analysis was going to have
too much air in it anyway is that what
you just said no no that's what uh not
was always saying so this F scores this
f1 score actually is the precision
recall comparing the patterns we mined
using the differential private version
compared to the non private version
which is treated as the ground truth
they should be yeah exactly so if this
one is the better show epsilon is big
enough to the orange and red lines to
get up to one is that what's happening
it doesn't it kind of a flat top plateau
here can't tell that's my point your
algorithm is implemented properly if
when you give them to thank infinite
privacy loss you don't get back the
answer that you would have gotten
without the privacy protection I think
the reason could be yeah actually that's
a very good point so I think the reason
is one of the some of these we did the
generalization of the using the ccs
category and we did kind of when you
generalize too much for example then the
valley could be the actual patterns may
not be able to be captured
but exactly yeah I think you've made a
very good challenging question but we
can discuss that offline
so that's for the temporal correlations
and then we started looking at can we
actually model the spatial correlations
meaning the co-occurrences among the
diagnosis code among the procedures and
so on see how often they correlate and
these correlations can we capture them
so a natural approach is we can model
these correlations or co-princes as a
graph so each patient we decided to
collapse the time so that we combine all
their procedures and medications into
one single big graph as long as during
each visit there's a co-occurrence
between a medication and diagnosis we
draw an edge between them so then at the
end we ended up having a bunch of input
graphs each graph corresponds to one
patient and the edges actually describes
the correlations among the different
diagnoses and concepts and then based on
this input graph population we can try
to find the sub graphs that are frequent
meaning these are probably interesting
significant co-occurrence patterns that
we can preserve and then again in order
to do this we developed some algorithms
for mining the frequency sub graphs
using differential privacy or based on
differential privacy so as you can see
okay this is still kind of piecemeal
based approach so how can we also this
is more explicitly defined based on
frequent patterns what if the pattern is
not very frequent or is not at the top
of the frequency list then we can't
really discover them so we right now
we're taking a more systematic tensor
driven based approach that are very good
at identifying or discovering more
latent medical concepts or spatial
temporal correlations so here is how we
model the data and how this tensor
factorization works as an example we can
will present our data using a 3-way
tensor right here we can actually use
multi-dimensional tensors but here is a
3-way tensor or 3mo tensor one dimension
is to patients one dimension is
medication one dimension is a diagnosis
so each cell of this tensor shows how
many times this medication m is
prescribed for diagnosis D for patient P
and then based on this data we can
factorize this tensor into a set of
hidden medical concept or components and
each component is represented as three
vectors and the product of each of these
value of these vectors can actually be
used to reconstruct the original tensor
the value of the original tensor so each
component we call a phenotype which
represents some clinical characteristics
or subpopulations and it has three
factors one is patient factor one is the
diagnosis factor or one is medication
factor if we look at it carefully or as
an example it basically shows the kind
of relationship or correlations among
these three dimensions so the this this
is a sample component it shows this is
the diagnosis is hypertension and then a
month along the medication dimension
there's three medications that are often
lis prescribed for this diagnosis and
then for the
patient factor about 40% of the patients
exhibited or contributed to this pattern
and of course you can think of this as
sort of like a fuzzy clustering of the
data so that you can identify these are
components or hidden latent concepts
medical concept that represents some
correlations or relationships among the
data and of course we also want to do
this in the collaborative way because
each site may have limited data so we
want to do this with multiple
institutions each contributing their own
data and at the end we want to have
these factorized tensors which are
simulating a centralized setting so
infatuated this is different from the
apple's federated setting where each
site is just the device here each site
is actual medical institution has a set
of medical data right so what we want to
do is using this federated setting where
the site does their own local tensor
factorizations and with some
coordination they can achieve some
consensus so that the diagnosis and
medication feature factors will be the
same which represent the shared
phenotypes but if we concatenate the
patient factor so these data are
horizontally distributed so if we
concatenate the patient factors they are
going to be essentially the same as if
we combine all the data integrate them
in a central place and do the
factorization and having these tensor
factors so how do we achieve this this
is a common federated or collaborative
learning setting that we have or we've
been using so essentially each local
site what does it slow on local
factorization so this is the original
tensor and it does its own local
factorization into the three feature
factor or factor matrices a and B and C
a represents the feature the patient
factor matrix and B and C represents the
medication and diagnosis factor matrices
and once it does its own local
factorization it can send the B and C
which are the feature factors just
represent the patterns in the
medications and diagnosis to a global
server and the global server once
receives all the local factors from the
local sites it can can do some average
or aggregation and update the global
factors and then send the global factors
to the local sites and the local sites
can do the updates again and do the
local factorization the process can
iterate until everything converges
everything so how do we achieve this
global consensus basically the calculus
here as you can see is that the patient
factor is never really shared to the
global server so that already gives us
some privacy guarantee but without
sharing this how do we actually achieve
the consensus on the B and C the feature
factors so this is the how the problem
is formulated the global optimization
problem we're trying to solve is looks
like this right we are trying to
minimize the loss between or the
approximation error or reconstruction
error between the original tensor all
suppose we have all the data aggregated
in
one big tensor and this is the
factorized tensor represented by the a
and B and C the factor matrices and we
have a constraint here that we need to
satisfy which is the consensus between
the feature factor matrices or the
diagnosis and medications so the B and C
at each side they should all agree again
those just represent the shared
phenotypes and in order to solve this
using the localized model basically we
would introduce a global variable B and
C which represent the global feature
factor matrices and solve it using the
elastic averaging SGD basically the
problem is reformulated with the local
optimization that looks like this again
so we're just gonna minimize the
reconstruction error between them all
and the local factor matrices but now
we're adding a penalty term which is
aimed to minimize the difference between
the local feature matrices and the
global Fisher matrices so the B hat and
C hat are a global version of the future
matrices so we want our local ones to
converge to be as close to the global
variable as possible and this row is
basically a lastik force you can think
of it as a term to adjust how close we
should be converge to the global
variable from the local variables
perspective so we can solve this using
basic SGD approaches at each local site
now given this as I mentioned there's
already some privacy that's built into
it because each side does not share the
patient factor to the global site but on
the other hand they do share the B and C
which are the medications and diagnosis
and they are actually learned based on
the patient information right so there's
obviously some privacy disclosure or
potential disclosure
so the you're setting this system up so
that the optimization can be done where
the in a way that the kind of
coordination between the different
instances is it's that the information
needed coordinate the instances as small
as possible
right is that it and specifically is it
going to be differentially private
that's it that's what we're gonna get
into the coordination you need here are
see exactly the coordination we need is
basically B T and C T from each side and
then the server just does some
aggregation in this case just averaging
them and then since back so exactly
that's what I'm getting to the next
point which is this intermediate
information that's shared by each side
we still need to make it formally
private and in this case we want to add
differential privacy to it did you
consider approaches that do like the
entire computation say within using
something like multi-party country those
would be alternative approaches yeah but
in this we were taking the differential
privacy disco computational
um so thank you for bringing that up
so our next question is how do we make
this differential private meaning making
sure the BT and CT these local feature
factors that are shared by each of this
local site satisfies differential
privacy so there are various points that
we can actually introduce this privacy
guarantee first is we can make the input
data entirely differential private if we
have the data that's already
differential private then we can do
anything on it but apparently that just
that's a chicken-egg problem so we want
eventually we want to achieve this but
then given this tensor factorization
problem we can also introduce the
perturbation at the optimizer level that
are used or STD level that are used for
solving these factorization problems or
we can directly perturb the output which
is BT and CD in this case B and C in
this case for each side and directly out
perturb the output so that it preserves
differential privacy and intuitively
which way would be better so for the
optimizer perturbation we would do this
optimization or SGD or updates for many
iterations before we send the output or
before we send the B and C to the server
so naturally it would be intuitively it
would be more noise effective if we
directly perturb the output because if
we perturb the optimizer or perturb the
gradient for the optimizer we need to do
it many many times before we update
before we update the feature attends our
feature factors so turns out in order to
do the output rotation
the key challenge is can we analyze the
sensitivity or can we bounce sensitivity
of these outputs and turns out our
optimization function here based on this
turns out it actually does have a nice
property it is Lipschitz continuous so
we came we can prove the gradient of
this is bounded by a Lipschitz constant
and with that is very nicely given some
previous result we can analyze
or bound l2 sensitivity of our objective
function basically it depends on tau
which is number of passes we do the PSG
D permutation besides Gd for each of the
epoch and then L is the Lipschitz
constant and ADA is the learning rate
so given this l2 sensitivity then we can
just use Gaussian mechanism to guarantee
epsilon Delta DP for each iteration and
then using a composition theorems we can
guarantee the overall differential
privacy of this so this analysis we just
did use the strong composition theorem
so it's still open question we're still
kind of exploring how we can use the
moment accountants to do even better or
tighter composition which is still kind
of not straight as straightforward or
not as easy for us so I would welcome
any help you may actually give us and
also the analysis of the o2 sensitivity
is not as trivial so I would I think
some of these automatic verification
Texas I would love to get them to kind
of help us verify the proof is correct
so given that we did some experiments
and the data set we use this mimic three
data set which are the publicly
available ICU data from multiple ICU
sites and we constructed tensors that
consists of basically forty thousand
patients about 200 procedures and three
hundred diagnosis and you can see the
data is very very sparse the non zero
ratio is very very low so data is very
very sparse that should that's why
traditional histogram based techniques
may not work very well for this kind of
data and this are the two phenotypes we
identified so the first one is from the
private differentially private version
and the second one is from the non
private version so which is like a
ground truth so these are the two most
similar patterns so you can see
apparently we introduced some noises to
the phenotypes that we discovered
because of the differential privacy
noise we injected into the B and C
feature factors even though there's so
you can see still see both of these are
kind of related to heart failure and
some hypertension
and some similar procedures but there
are some noises in there this is I
believe is one of these Epsilon's either
one or somewhere around if you take this
one to epsilon of Tim do they agree it
would be better they would be better and
but my point is so this if you present
this to a medical clinic they may they
may found it not very acceptable as some
noises in a phenotype however we did a
study that let's take these phenotypes
we discovered and use them as features
meaning looking at the membership of
each patient given these phenotypes and
if we use these for predictive studies
for some outcomes hospital readmission
or mortality study turns out the utility
is actually very very good I really need
to look at the paper which is in
submission the epsilon values
corresponding to this but I think is in
a range of one so here we actually shows
the rank is basically the number of
components we have in the original CPT
composition picture if you remember and
then this is the deep effect the
differentially private version and this
is the version without the differential
privacy and these are some this is the
centralized version this is another
federated version using another
different kind of optimization technique
the ADM M based approach so what we can
observe here is that this is the AUC the
predictive performance the area under
the curve for the mortality study for
predicting the mortality and we can see
the AUC are very very similar for the
differential private version and non
differentially private version so this I
think is an interesting insight because
at the surface the phenotypes may be
noisy but their predictive power are
actually very good which is kind of
promising
and so so far those are still kind of
descriptive and we still thought we are
a few years into the project I always
tell people I feel like we failed the
project because we didn't really deliver
what we promise we still don't have a
tool that we can give the medical
researchers say okay this is a synthetic
given the original data this is a
synthetic data you can have and you can
use and you can do whatever with it and
we still can't do that so right now
we're actually trying to this pursue
this with all these deep learning model
that are available we're trying to see
if we can use these deep learning models
to help us generate synthetic data that
are really preserving the spatial and
temporal properties within a data right
so LST M the typical RM model is very
good at model in temporal dependencies
and then this graph networks like GCM
it's very good at modeling the graph
correlations or spatial correlations so
can we combine this to preserve both
spatial and temporal correlations and
then use the GAM based approach combined
with the auto-encoders so basically we
would have the encoder here which takes
the input data and learn some
distribution and then we have a decoder
here that can take the distribution and
sample output data that kind of
preserves the original distribution
within the data and we would have a
discriminator here kind of making sure
these input and output are similar
enough so that preserves the original
property of the data and we also have
some other regulations that are kind of
designed to preserve the phenotypes
within a day that kind of the hero and
the phenotypes within the data so in a
way this looks like a kind of kitchen
sink approach and if we do this
successfully then our goal may be
achieved which is to generate synthetic
data that actually preserves the
original distribution in particular
spatial temporal correlations but then
what's the challenge here what's the
we're actually even not sure if this is
feasible because based on our previous
experience even adding some noise to
deep learning model very simple deep
learning models like CNN can actually
degrade the utility but here we're
actually dealing with these huge neural
networks with probably millions of
Amador's and if we are adding the
differential private noise into air to
make sure this model is differential
private then it's really not clear to us
if it's feasible in terms of getting
reasonable utility but we're trying to
explore along this direction so that's
kind of wrapping up our effort in terms
of trying to model the spatial temporal
correlations within these data in
particularly in this medical data
concept to enhance the utility to
preserve these spatial temporal
correlations so the flip side of the
story I want to briefly share with you I
probably don't have five minutes left is
looking at the other application I just
mentioned the location based services
setting where in those cases that
spatial or temporal patterns can be more
easily learned and typically can be
learned for example based on the Markov
model like diverse west nation or using
in his work and the flipside is what if
the adversary knows the model then
what's gonna happen and how can we
actually utilize this or model this
explicitly to get us better utility
guarantee so here's the problem setting
we have a mobile user that walks or
travels on a map and occasionally he
would share its location to the privacy
through a privacy mechanism to a
location-based services like a Yelp or
some location-based app and the point is
we're going to perturb the true location
into a perturb location so that we do
not disclose the exact location of the
user and all these two locations
apparently they follow some mobility
pattern and what we're gonna assume here
is that we actually knows the pattern so
if the address knows the pattern of the
mobility then whatever I released here
as a per trip location can help the
adverse between fur his future locations
so if we simply perturb each location
independently then the privacy guarantee
may not hold because of the inference
possible inference so that's why in our
work along this line we're trying to
model the spatial temporal correlations
explicitly and maybe even factor that
into our definition privacy definition
so this could be for example by Rho
constraint right I know okay after you
visited for example if I see you at this
meeting place at one time point I know
with 50% probability or in extreme cases
a hundred percent proper who you're
going to be at the coffee shop at next
time point so if I release a perturb
location of you at this time point and a
perturb location and next time point the
peripheral location of the previous time
point can be used to infer or stress the
s strengths in the estimate for your
location at the next time point very
good point so in our work we actually
did both we tried the personal
trajectory based knowledge and the
population based knowledge so obviously
the population based knowledge is less
accurate does not may not directly
follow your own trajectory but still it
can have some impact
in the previous so in in our current
effort we're trying to use a neural
network based approach where we can use
the graphical convolution networks to
model the spatial correlations and ours
TM or RM based approaches to model the
temporal correlations
so given this problem setting if we look
back originally the most standard
approach we can use is the event level
differential privacy by ensuring any two
locations produce similar or
indistinguishable output or perturb
locations so this is just a direct
application of the event level DP you
can also think of it as a local DP but
the difference here is that local TP is
typically studied in a setting that you
are aggregating millions of users and
their usage scenarios and stuff but here
we only have one single user so our goal
is a little different our goal is to
support accuracy for individual queries
so we want the perturb location to be as
close to the original location as
possible while still satisfying this
differential privacy guarantee so
obviously if we use this direct event
level base TP or local TP directly the
challenge is this large input domain on
the map right we want to guarantee any
two locations on the map to be
indistinguishable it's just not gonna be
possible so the output location is not
gonna be very useful at all so then
that's why the geo indistinguishability
come along it was proposed in 2013
basically relaxed the event level
differential privacy by this distance
factor so it scales the
indistinguishability by the distance
between each pair of locations so it's
also very intuitive right if a pair of
location are very far away you can
tolerate a higher level of or lower
level of indistinguishability so
basically the are the epsilon is scaled
by the difference by the distance
between the pair of locations x and y so
this gives us a more enhanced or relaxed
notion of privacy and probably enhanced
utility or feasible utility however it
still does not consider the temporal
correlations so our main viewpoint is
that if the adversary knows the public
knowledge or through private learning
knows your parent knows your mobility
pattern then there's no point to make
sure to enforce the indistinguishability
between any pair of locations we only
need to hide a true location within a
set of probable
locations based on the mobility
inference that adversary' can do so then
becomes we're gonna guarantee any two
locations in the probable set they're
gonna produce similar distributions
proportional to the distance or
indistinguishable distributions and this
probable set is done by this Markov
chain based model so we assume the
original user have these unobservable
trajectory and H location we have or
each possible perturb location we have a
perturb location which is observable and
for as the adversary given this mobility
pattern that actually guides this
process this Markov process and given
this perturb locations I can actually
infer at each time point what are the
probable locations for the users
location and then based on the proper
set we can do the differential privacy
and make sure to pair of locations
within this probable set are
indistinguishable so here our assumption
is the adversary knows the Markov model
which is the Markov model in this markov
chain or transition matrix
[Music]
so that's based on so these values these
variables are unobservable but the
actual transition matrix that garments
these variables are no that's our
assumption
which you assume the addressee can learn
from either public data or private data
we can talk later
so given that now our problem becomes a
optimal perturbation or optimization
problem where we want to satisfy this
guarantee privacy guarantee and at the
same time we want to minimize the
expected distance of the perturb
location and the original location and
turns out the Laplace mechanism is not
optimal and we develop the optimal
mechanism called planner isotropic
mechanism and this is just an
illustration of given original
trajectory this is how a Laplace
mechanism would give you as a perturb
trajectory and this is the trajectory
that are generated by our mechanism and
the point here is that both of these
actually satisfy the same level of
privacy so given the privacy guarantee
the optimal mechanism obviously gives us
better utility in terms of the distance
between the perturb location and the
original location and so that's just
location privacy for protecting a user's
location at each time point and along
this line of work we started thinking
okay what about spatial temporal
activities if a user stays at a hospital
for two hours or if a user commutes from
the home to office every day or every
Monday these kind of activities what if
these are secret we only want to protect
this and I don't mind if my location at
particular time points gets disclosed I
only want to keep this events as a
secret so we started looking at how do
we define and represent these spatial
temporal events and we developed a
boolean expression based representation
to define these events and then we
define a spatial temporal event privacy
so if you think of location privacy as
two locations produce similar outputs
here our notion is that a true event and
an active event would produce similar
observations I think my time is up so
just live it here and so to summarize
our main lessons that we learn is that
the spatial temporal correlations can be
a two-edged sword so if we use it wisely
we can improve our utility of the data
but if we don't model explicitly or
carefully it may degrade or downgrade
the privacy guarantee but on the other
hand we can still turn it into our usage
so at the end I want to thank
my students in the lab who is behind its
work but for privacy reasons let's just
call them Charlie's Angels the
assumption that in that relationship
that she just gave up and you get
extremely high from security for that
but here where I should be you know
having fun surfing that's one level
deeper even the semantics associated
with what you do at the location right
many cases it would be that you know I
would care about whether you learn
within here where I'm not supposed to be
and the other question is other concern
is about join theme parks event primacy
in this setting and in at least in the
technical sense like there is a sense
like isn't it man - what did I move the
from - event is it like every second
every day every hour and if you're only
protecting you know this separately or
every second the pain probably after an
hour there's enough information
actually learn what they did you are
free with our show this young la thing I
think is also an issue
yeah the granularity is a very good
point so for this work for the Delta
location set based privacy work we're
basically protecting the users current
location and current time point and as
you move then we don't have any
quantifiable guarantee for your location
at the previous time point so it's
always just real-time protection
so it's kind of orthogonal to the
granularity that notion but of course as
future work as you mentioned the
granularity is very very important to
protect against a stalker is that is
that the kind of adversary then you have
in mind that could be that one but I
still don't see white would protect all
right we're gonna have to take this at
the break thank you very much
thank you